We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21centry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. And we have a special podcast edition of the show this week because I'm off the radio, airing repeats until February 4th, when season number two of 99% Invisible
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州乃至全球范围内合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21centry.ucdavis.edu。这里是《99% Invisible》。我是 Roman Mars。本周我们有一期特别的播客节目，因为我暂时离开了广播，在 2 月 4 日第二季《99% Invisible》开播之前，我们一直在重播旧节目。
starts up. We had some funding to start up, and I'm sort of getting more funding and researching and recording starts up. We had some funding to start up and I'm sort of getting more funding and researching and recording more stories. So look for new episodes on February 4th. But in the meantime, I have probably what are going to be new stories to you unless you already listen to a lot of the shows that I've worked on in the past. And this one is from one of those shows called Snap Judgment. The best new storytelling show out there, it's from NPR and PRX. You should definitely check it out if you haven't already. But this is a piece that I really love that I did for them for the Utopia episode.
我们有一些启动资金，我正在筹集更多资金，并研究和录制更多故事。所以请期待 2 月 4 日的新剧集。但在此期间，我带来的可能对你来说是新故事，除非你已经听过很多我过去参与制作的节目。这一期来自我参与过的节目之一，叫《Snap Judgment》。这是目前最好的新故事讲述节目，来自 NPR 和 PRX。如果你还没听过，一定要去听听。这是我为他们的“乌托邦”一期节目制作的，我非常喜欢。
And I think it has some design implications. So if you can bear with me, you know, but otherwise it's just, I think it's a fun one to listen to because there's some great tape in the end. So like stay with it because the tape in the end is just, it'll just destroy you. It's about an online world that was designed and created by EA Games and sort of turned into a perfect little utopia by the users themselves. But the problem was, is that EA Games didn't actually make any money off the game, so they didn't support it anymore.
我认为它包含了一些设计层面的启示。所以，如果你能耐心听完，那很好；如果不行，我认为它本身也是一个很有趣的故事，因为最后有一段很棒的录音。一定要坚持听完，因为最后的录音真的会让你心碎。这是一个由 EA Games 设计和创建的在线世界，被用户自己变成了一个完美的乌托邦。但问题是，EA Games 并没有从这个游戏中赚到钱，所以他们不再支持它了。
So it's what happens when a created world goes dark. I hope you enjoy it. A few months before the end of the world, Paul Monaco posted this message on YouTube. Hello, everyone. Paul Monaco here, Buddha Paul, is most of you. Know me as... You probably all heard the news,
所以，这就是当一个创造出来的世界走向终结时会发生的事情。希望你喜欢。在世界末日的前几个月，Paul Monaco 在 YouTube 上发布了这条信息。大家好，我是 Paul Monaco，也就是你们大多数人所知的 Buddha Paul……你们可能都听说了这个消息，
Yeeland, the Simpsons Online, closing down. The world that was ending was called The Sims Online. It was an online version of the most popular computer game ever made. You've all been wonderful, you helped me through a hard time in my life when I first got online. But ironically, the online version of the Sims was not very popular. They ended up losing tons of subscribers and changing the name to EA Land, and then they finally pulled the plug. Thank you, and that, please. Let's try to stay in touch. And if not, go back with whatever you choose to do and move on to.
EA Land，《模拟人生在线版》要关闭了。那个即将终结的世界叫《模拟人生在线版》。它是史上最受欢迎的电脑游戏的在线版本。你们都太棒了，当我刚上网时，你们陪我度过了人生中最艰难的时刻。但讽刺的是，在线版的《模拟人生》并不太受欢迎。他们最终流失了大量订阅用户，改名为 EA Land，最后彻底关停了服务器。谢谢大家，就这样吧。让我们保持联系。如果不行，那就去做你们选择做的事，继续前行。
As you can probably hear, EA Land was not a normal video game. There were no monsters, no killing, and although it had some competitive elements, for many players, competition wasn't the point at all. Unlike a lot of other games where you might be shooting people or slaying dragons or something This was a game about socializing. That is Robert Ashley and Robert Ashley He produces a very popular internet radio show and the creator of a life well-wasted a life well-wasted It's about video games and the people who love them and EA land was a video game that a dedicated few Absolutely loved the crowd that had attracted I think,
正如你可能听到的，EA Land 不是一个普通的游戏。没有怪物，没有杀戮，虽然它有一些竞争元素，但对许多玩家来说，竞争根本不是重点。不像许多其他游戏，你可能在射击别人或屠龙什么的，这是一个关于社交的游戏。那是 Robert Ashley，他制作了一个非常受欢迎的网络广播节目，也是《A Life Well-Wasted》的创作者。《A Life Well-Wasted》是关于电子游戏和热爱它们的人的，而 EA Land 是一个被少数忠实玩家绝对热爱的游戏。它吸引的人群，我想，
were people who just wanted to get together and sort of chat, meet strangers. It was a nice place. Over time, it became a kind of intimate, almost bar, like the cheers of video games. Where everyone knows your name. And at the moment that Paul Monaco, aka Buddha Paul, found E.A. Land, It was exactly what he needed most.
是那些只想聚在一起聊天、结识陌生人的人。那是一个美好的地方。随着时间的推移，它变成了一种亲密的、几乎像酒吧一样的地方，就像电子游戏界的《欢乐酒店》（Cheers）。每个人都知道你的名字。在 Paul Monaco，也就是 Buddha Paul 发现 EA Land 的那一刻，这正是他最需要的。
My wife had a long-term illness. From a blood transfusion she had hepatitis C. And the last three years or so of her life were pretty much a challenge for both of us. And after she passed away, I had absolutely no function of the to wake up, go to work and go to sleep again. With her illness, I didn't get out of socialized much. We weren't able to go out to the bars and meet up with friends and have dinner. I totally dessocialized myself. And this game was kind of a way for me to just kind of get back into into living again. It was it was pretty amazing. And Paul began to live for E.A.L.A. He would play it for hours and hours.
我妻子患有长期疾病。因为一次输血，她感染了丙型肝炎。她生命中最后三年左右的时间对我们俩来说都是一种挑战。在她去世后，我完全失去了生活的动力，只是起床、上班、睡觉。因为她的病，我没有太多社交。我们无法去酒吧、见朋友或共进晚餐。我完全与社会隔绝了。而这个游戏是我重新开始生活的一种方式。这真的很神奇。Paul 开始为 EA Land 而活。他会玩上好几个小时。
It was the first thing he did when he got home from work. You treated to a big warm greeting everyone would you know say hi and you know your your I.M.s would be beeping along and you'd be in and taking with that. It made you feel really good. It wasn't the real world, but his friends were real friends. And virtual worlds do have an upside. You erase your colleague who you were mentioned. All that can be totally masked and you're truly judged
这是他下班回家后做的第一件事。你会得到热情的问候，每个人都会说你好，你的即时通讯软件会滴滴作响，你会沉浸其中。这让你感觉非常好。这不是现实世界，但他的朋友是真实的朋友。虚拟世界确实有其优势。你抹去了你的同事身份。所有这些都可以被完全掩盖，你真正被评判的，
on who you really are and how you present yourself. There's no prejudice, there's no preconceived anything. You're really taking that face value. People could really like break loose and in-be themselves and have some fun. It just feels really good. But Paul's utopia didn't last because E.A.L.A.N. started hemorrhaging money. The riding was on the wall, the server was about to go dark. And this event, this virtual
是你真实的样子以及你如何展现自己。没有偏见，没有先入为主的观念。你真的被按面值对待。人们可以真正地释放自我，做回自己，享受乐趣。感觉真的很好。但 Paul 的乌托邦并没有持续下去，因为 EA Land 开始亏损。大势已去，服务器即将变黑。而这个事件，这个虚拟的
apocalypse, might only exist in the memory of the players if it weren't for Dr. Henry Lowe Wood. I just stumbled across this project by Henry Lowe Wood. My name is Henry Lowe Wood, who is this archival researcher at Stanford. And I had a project called How They Got Game, which is on the history of digital games and simulations. Saving video games for future generations. You know, 50, 100, 200 years from now.
末日，如果不是因为 Henry Lowood 博士，可能只会存在于玩家的记忆中。我偶然发现了 Henry Lowood 的这个项目。我是 Henry Lowood，他是斯坦福大学的一名档案研究员。我有一个项目叫“他们是如何获得游戏的”（How They Got Game），是关于数字游戏和模拟的历史。为后代保存电子游戏。你知道，50 年、100 年、200 年后。
How are we going to save that history? You know, like, we've got to save the video games. So Dr. Lowwood and his colleagues preserve what happens inside video games. Now, for a single-player game, like Pac-Man, for example, this is easy. You effectively take the Atari cartridge out and you put it on a shelf.
我们该如何保存那段历史？你知道，我们必须保存这些电子游戏。所以 Lowood 博士和他的同事们保存了电子游戏内部发生的事情。现在，对于像《吃豆人》这样的单机游戏，这很容易。你只需把 Atari 卡带取出来放在架子上就行了。
But saving multiplayer online games is not so simple. Saving the software alone is kind of a barren exercise. If you save the code for the A-Land and turn it on 100 years now, you'd enter a world and nothing would be there. All the things that Paul Monaco and his friends loved would be impossible to find. You need to document what people are doing in these spaces.
但保存多人在线游戏就没那么简单了。仅仅保存软件是一种徒劳的练习。如果你保存了 EA Land 的代码并在 100 年后运行它，你进入的世界将空无一物。Paul Monaco 和他的朋友们所珍视的一切都将无法找到。你需要记录人们在这些空间里所做的事情。
That situation is much more like what a historian on archivists would do when faced with the problem of documenting the real world. So when Dr. Lowood caught wind of the alien shutting down, he had the opportunity to record something to historian or archaeologist would die to witness firsthand in the real world. To see what it would be like when an online world came to an end. What happens when a virtual world closes? The end of a culture. What is it like to be there in the last minute when it shuts down?
这种情况更像是历史学家或档案管理员在面对记录现实世界的问题时所做的事情。所以当 Lowood 博士听到 EA Land 即将关闭的消息时，他有机会记录下一些历史学家或考古学家在现实世界中梦寐以求亲眼见证的事情。看看当一个在线世界终结时会是什么样子。当一个虚拟世界关闭时会发生什么？一种文化的终结。在它关闭的最后一分钟身处其中是什么感觉？
So the tape is rolling in the last few hours of the Alien are being recorded and the most dedicated die-hard users are there. Exchanging virtual hugs, reminiscing. The players are typing messages which appear like comic book word bubbles. And you hear all these avatars crying and you hear all these coos and moans and the gibberish language of the game called simlish. And you know they sound like they're going to be bummed and everything, but it's not like a big pity party. But then toward the end of the night, there's this radio station that you can listen to in the game called Charmed Radio.
所以录音机在运行，EA Land 最后几个小时被记录了下来，最忠实的死忠用户都在那里。交换虚拟拥抱，回忆往事。玩家们输入的信息像漫画书里的对话气泡一样出现。你可以听到所有这些化身在哭泣，听到他们的咕哝声和呻吟声，以及游戏中那种叫“模拟语”（Simlish）的胡言乱语。你知道他们听起来会很沮丧，但这并不是一场大型的同情派对。但在深夜临近结束时，游戏里有一个你可以收听的广播电台，叫 Charmed Radio。
And they had this DJ there named Spike. He is sort of the only voice that you end up hearing at the end of the world. And as soon as he starts talking, you understand what is being lost. spike, he is sort of the only voice that you end up hearing at the end of the world. And as soon as he starts talking, you understand what is being lost. Hey guys, the last time you're going to have me speak, well, the last time the 4TS like goes down. I just want to thank you all, it's been an amazing experience it really has and I promise I wouldn my myself cry but I can't I can't stress enough how much you guys have been to me over the past however many years it's been really has been awesome add some people don't get attached to thing but when you make friends I look people having this game
他们有一位 DJ 叫 Spike。他是你在世界末日时唯一能听到的声音。当他开始说话时，你就明白了什么是正在失去的。Spike，他是你在世界末日时唯一能听到的声音。当他开始说话时，你就明白了什么是正在失去的。嘿，伙计们，这是你们最后一次听我说话了，好吧，这是 4TS 最后一次下线。我只想感谢你们所有人，这是一次了不起的经历，真的。我保证我不会让自己哭，但我无法强调过去这些年你们对我来说有多重要，这真的很棒。有些人不会对事物产生依恋，但当你在这个游戏中结交朋友时，
it's actually really hard so i'm gonna play the last song it's Sarah Brite, I'm in an Andrea Brichelli time to say goodbye hopefully you guys will like,. It's been such a long time. My idea is 1,2,3,4,5. 2,3,4,5. Are you alright? 1,2,3,4,5. You're lucky in life, everybody.
这真的很难，所以我打算播放最后一首歌，是 Sarah Brightman 和 Andrea Bocelli 的《Time to Say Goodbye》，希望你们会喜欢。已经过去这么久了。我的 ID 是 1,2,3,4,5。2,3,4,5。你们还好吗？1,2,3,4,5。祝你们生活幸运，每个人。
And the best wishes. I love you all and that's been great knowing you. Take care guys and I just want to, even if you haven't got a drink, this proposes a toast to Parasad, who's been an absolutely amazing Parasad, but you can have done this without you. Thank you.
祝你们一切顺利。我爱你们所有人，认识你们真是太好了。保重，伙计们，我只想，即使你没有喝的，也请为 Parasad 举杯，他一直是一个绝对了不起的 Parasad，没有你我们做不到。谢谢。
Thank you. Thank you. Say goodbye. You get this feeling like being on the deck of the Titanic. Anyone who actually stayed to the end was very much invested in the game on an emotional level. When they pulled the plug on the server, bits and pieces of the world started disappearing.
谢谢。谢谢。说再见吧。你会有一种身处泰坦尼克号甲板上的感觉。任何真正坚持到最后的人都在情感层面上对这个游戏投入了极大的感情。当他们拔掉服务器插头时，这个世界的点点滴滴开始消失。
The environment began to disintegrate. The texture on the trees flickered, and all the people froze, and blinked out of existence. The actual ending was, you know, not with a bang, with a whimper. And the last thing that they saw was basically just an error message, a server disconnect message. And then the world ended. That was a game over for a show I worked on called snap judgment Which if you not already a fan you should just go and trust me and just download everything and listen to it You'll enjoy it and it also was a collaboration with Robert Ashley who who did the internet radio, so-called, a life well-wasted.
环境开始瓦解。树木上的纹理闪烁，所有人都冻结了，然后消失得无影无踪。真正的结局，你知道，不是一声巨响，而是一声呜咽。他们看到的最后一件事基本上只是一个错误信息，一个服务器断开连接的信息。然后世界就结束了。这就是我参与制作的节目《Snap Judgment》的游戏结束时刻，如果你还不是粉丝，你应该相信我，下载所有节目听听。你会喜欢的。这也是与 Robert Ashley 的合作，他制作了那个网络广播《A Life Well-Wasted》。
I heard that the bit of audio tape and the interview that he did about this story on his podcast, and I asked him about it, and we sort of interviewed him, and kind of rearranged the parts, and took little bits of it, and turned into the piece that you heard. So this is definitely a collaboration with Robert Ashley.
我在他的播客中听到了关于这个故事的音频片段和采访，我问了他这件事，我们采访了他，重新整理了部分内容，取了一些片段，变成了你听到的这个作品。所以这绝对是与 Robert Ashley 的合作。
The last episode of his show, I have episode number six of a Life Well Wasted, is a work of art. It's just beautiful. So go look that up, the Life Well Wasted, and down on it. That's the piece for this week. I have another one coming, I think next week,
他的节目最后一集，也就是《A Life Well-Wasted》的第六集，是一件艺术品。它太美了。所以去搜一下《A Life Well-Wasted》并下载它。这就是本周的作品。我想下周还有一期，
or in two weeks, before the new show's start on February 4th. And really, any ideas I have another one coming, I think, next week or in two weeks before the new show's start on February 4th. And really, any ideas you have, design stories, anything, pitch me something, I respond really well to pitches. So let me know what you're thinking about and what type of stories you'd like to hear on an Interest in Visible. Go to 90%invisible.org.
或者两周内，在新节目 2 月 4 日开播之前。真的，任何想法，我想下周或两周内还有一期，在新节目 2 月 4 日开播之前。真的，你有任何想法，设计故事，任何东西，向我推销吧，我对推销的反应很好。所以让我知道你在想什么，以及你想在《99% Invisible》中听到什么样的故事。去 90percentinvisible.org 看看。
And thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。